Well, actually, I’ve always been interested
in bees.
They’re the pinnacle of social evolution,
really, in the whole animal kingdom.
But my interest in their gut bacteria in particular
developed when there was a study right after
the first colony collapse event which was
2007.
There was a study of the organisms associated
with bees in attempt to find what disease
organism might be involved.
And one thing that came out of that — it
didn’t identify a disease organism, but
it did show that there was a set number of
bacteria that live in every single honeybee
everywhere in the world and that these are
dominating the gut of those bees.
And that made me think this is a good system
for really looking at a very specialized community
that’s probably doing something important
in bees.